[Música]
y nuestro segundo invitado del día es
oscar vela él es escritor también
abogado de ecuatoriano hablando de su
novela los crímenes de bartow oscar
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francés de 4 para
nosotros es un gusto que estés aquí
conversando con nosotros sobre esta
novela los crímenes de bartow de que se
trata de que está esta novela oscar
bueno muchas gracias el gusto es mío y
el honor gracias por la invitación
a ver esta es la historia de un
empresario nelson serrano sáenz un
hombre que era muy exitoso en los eeuu
tenía una empresa
importante grande con una facturación
muy grande estamos hablando de alrededor
de 1997 y de pronto la vida se le
destruyen en diciembre 1990 y te le
acusan de cuatro crímenes brutales los
crímenes más importantes más fuertes que
se provocaron en el condado de polk en
el centro norte de florida en la ciudad
de barto precisamente lo que le acusan
de estos crímenes y bueno ahí comienza
su la historia la historia más triste de
su vida él comienza a investigar
una sola prueba él de hecho demostró que
estaba en otro lugar en la planta a
muchas millas de distancia 500 millas de
distancia del lugar del crimen y sin
embargo le terminan fabricando una
prueba años después le secuestran en
quito ecuador en el año 2002 y desde
entonces desde el día primero de
septiembre del año 2002 hasta hoy 20
años ya está preso en el corredor de la
muerte con cuatro condenas de encima de
él cuatro contenido pena de muerte oscar
tengo tengo muchas preguntas pero lo
primero que le quiero preguntar es cómo
lo van a secuestrar de su país digamos
el estado ecuatoriano tiene de alguna
alguna implicación a algo algo que ver
con este secuestro como dejaron que
secuestrar anunciada no y llevarlo eeuu
además así como así usted también decía
que fue totalmente sin papeles sin
documentos como ocurrió hasta además
montaba un vuelo comercial no increíble
es de una historia que cuando se la
cuenta a nadie nadie la puede creer como
si hoy día te secuestran a ti en tu
propio país sin un solo documento te
trasladan a cualquier país del mundo
digamos a los eeuu
y eso le pasó a nelson en quito de
ecuador en el año del año 2002 no
secuestraron de un restaurante lo
metieron le torturaron le golpearon
intentaron arrancarle una confesión nos
secuestraron 14 policías ecuatorianos
sobornados por un policía americano y un
fiscal americano que es el que enjuician
el show si el fiscal y el policía fueron
a quito para secuestrar a una persona
trasladar los sin papeles golpearlo
torturarlo le metieron en una jaula de
perros del antiguo aeropuerto de quito
del antiguo del viejo aeropuerto de
quito lo encerraron durante toda una
noche en esa jaula de perros y al día
siguiente a las 6 de la mañana se lo
llevaron a un vuelo comercial de
american airlines con la complicidad de
todo el mundo autoridades ecuatorianas
pilotos azafatas todo el mundo claro era
un policía americano y un fiscal
americano con poder y una persona que
fue la que tramó todo esto que era un
funcionario además de la dea en el
ecuador en aquel entonces quién está
detrás de nelson por qué tan importante
porque para ellos no era tan importante
era un caso importante digamos en un
barco digámoslo chavista pero yo le digo
oscar por qué hacer
o sea se puede comparar con la fuga del
chapo en la cárcel es decir casi dije
casa a ver por qué era tan importante
porque tanto para la policía como para
los fiscales en los eeuu todos los casos
de estos en donde existen crímenes
atroces crímenes brutales y hay un
responsable ya señalado y ha acusado
necesitan resolverlos lo antes posible
ellos viven en definitiva de condenar
gente si es que tú no logras condena si
no logras penas de muerte si no logras
cadenas perpetuas con la gente a la que
estás persiguiendo o señalando como como
autores de un crimen tú no renueva tu
carrera a ellos se les terminaba en el
año 2002 precisamente justo cuando
ocurrió el secuestro se les terminaba su
carrera ya porque no habían descubierto
a ninguno de los autores de los crímenes
de barto que era el crimen más
importante de la zona ya le tenían a
nelson serrano que evidentemente era
ecuatoriano digamos latino le decían el
mexicano respectivamente así lo trataban
siempre despectivamente como el mexicano
todos somos de mexico para abajo todos
somos mexicanos
y necesitaban un culpable y ese culpable
sólo podía ser nelson porque porque los
culpables verdaderos y es un poco lo que
cuenta en la novela los culpables
verdaderos eran miembros de una mafia y
una de las víctimas de un muchacho que
estaba metido en drogas en un problema
muy serio de drogas muy grave con una
deuda importante con un mafioso de nueva
york nadie quería meterse con el mafioso
de nueva york que es el autor de los
crímenes de autor intelectual
nadie quería buscar a los sicarios
auténticos porque estuvo un sicariato
qué sé yo y tenías un hombre que era
vulnerable que era latino funciona mucho
la xenofobia y en eeuu y necesitaba
seguir tu carrera entonces por qué no
arriesgarse a secuestrar a un tipo si al
final es un ecuatoriano y un colombiano
mexicano de los mismos y nosotros somos
basura para ellos
oscar digamos que este caso con estas
pruebas cuando ya se puede comprobar
digamos que quienes son es inocente que
sigue para este caso
va a haber un refugio se puede decir así
nos guste me corrige que es abogado de
un nuevo juicio para de presentar toda
esta evidencia que usted también
encontró en su investigación el que va a
pasar porque sigue preso a ver él está
como te digo 20 años por eso él tiene
una condena de cuatro penas de muerte y
si él tiene dos recursos todavía
judiciales es hay una hay un juicio de
resentencia que se llama en los eeuu que
hay que agotar lo hay que hacerlo
necesariamente y es el recurso en el que
solamente le pueden quitar la pena de
muerte le quita la pena de muerte le dan
cadena perpetua pero es un recurso que
hay que agotar es indispensable votarlo
en ese recurso ese recurso está
postergado digamos detenido desde hace
más o menos cuatro años en los eeuu
porque nadie en la fiscalía de barto
quiere tocar el tema ni los jueces ni
los fiscales ni los policías quieren que
toquemos este tema porque saben que
desde hace aproximadamente dos o tres
años hemos descubierto todas las pruebas
del fraude procesal todas las pruebas de
corrupción los testigos ocultos las
pruebas de quienes son los verdaderos
autores de los crímenes las pruebas del
mafioso que ordenó los crímenes las
pruebas de armas que ocultaron por
ejemplo de la escena del crimen y se las
guardaron muchas cosas que se
descubrieron hace tres años
aproximadamente un proceso de
investigación largo a nadie le interesa
tocar este caso a la corte de florida -
todavía y si hay dos recursos pendientes
pero nelson tiene 83 años y está muy
grave de salud muy delicado entonces de
ellos lo que están esperando y ido
seguramente yo hacen todo lo posible
todo los días para que nelson muera
porque ellos creen que el momento que
nelson muera entonces este proceso se va
a quedar tranquilo ya nadie va a
seguirlo y es algo que se lo hemos dicho
permanentemente el día que en el
software a este caso va a seguir su
familia está ahí hasta hasta el final o
sea va a haber un día ojalá sea pronto
sino será en décadas y yo probablemente
ya no esté aquí ni sus hijos pero
alguien va a descubrir la verdad y la
verdad va a salir a la luz con nelson
muerto inclusive ejecutado o muerto
naturalmente pero va a salir la luz a la
luz la verdad es cómo es la vida en eso
en la cárcel en una persona de 83 años
como usted lo dice en la cárcel no es
ser fácil no haber es una vida no sé si
es vida del zombi ve en una celda de dos
por tres metros
tiene una cama muy estrecha y está muy
pequeña y tiene solamente un servicio
higiénico y un lavabo y puede vivir ahí
con unas poquitas cosas le permiten
tener libros y la vida de nelson ha sido
leer ha leído más de mil y pico de
libros en todo este tiempo es un gran
lector
y así se pasa la vida desafortunadamente
está quedándose ciego él ya perdió la
visión de un ojo y le queda el dice nos
dice a todos que le quedan él calcula
que unos pocos meses de visión ya no va
a poder leer
imagínate lo que es vivir encerrado toda
tu vida sale pasando un día para bañarse
durante 10 minutos no ha visto la luna
desde hace 20 años porque tiene una
pequeña ventanita por la que nunca ha
podido ver la luna bell sólo
ocasionalmente porque les permiten salir
dos veces a la semana a un jardín
durante unas horas donde puedes estar
simplemente ahí parado y mirando al sol
nunca ha visto la luna me he contado la
luna desde hace 20 años y lo único con
lo que sueña evidentemente es estar
libre y volverá a su país volver al
ecuador y ver los volcanes y el mes y
ahí caminar en los maizales él cree que
todavía y maizales de la zona donde
vivía ya no hay ahora es una zona urbana
necesario luego quisieras caminar en tus
maizales de ahí en esa zona de tumbaco
donde donde él vivía en quito y ese su
aspiración él
y yo creo que ya va perdiendo la fe poco
a poco imaginan si se queda cierto
ustedes han perdido la fe oscar en este
caso y además le quiero preguntar si no
ha sentido o no ha tenido algún tipo de
amenaza e intimidación hostigamiento
durante todo este caso como usted lo
dice nadie lo quiere tocar y seguramente
nadie lo va a tocar por años y que se
puede hacer para que realmente alguien
en eeuu la justicia sobre todo les habla
prioridad dónde está dónde está serrano
qué tiene que tiene que pasar para que
realmente vuelvan a hacerle el proceso
el debido proceso si nosotros no
perdemos la fe nosotros ya hablo
siempre por mí y por su hijo francisco
seguramente y sus hijas o sea no
perdemos la fe porque porque seguimos
aquí esta es una batalla que la vamos a
dar hasta el final sea cual sea
es un tema complejo por supuesto muy muy
difícil de tratar pero vamos a estar ahí
respecto a las intimidaciones no he
recibido todavía la mejor sí pero parte
de lo que estamos haciendo de esto es
divulgar esta historia y es este libro
nos ha permitido poner el caso
nuevamente en todos los medios de
comunicación sobre todo en los eeuu sí
claro claro colombia ecuador perú
etcétera pero sobre todo los estados
necesitan los medios
se toma la voz de alguna forma vino en
el libro sé por qué y nelson me decía
bien yo nunca perdió un documental
también no va a haber un documental gay
pero ahí hay un documental de la cbs que
es que es armado en contra de nelson
serrano y le tratan como un criminal en
serie y hay otro documental muy muy
interesante que es de una periodista
ecuatoriana de aled inostrosa que es muy
bueno que en realidad es lo que hace es
desmontar la teoría de la fiscalía y
demuestra como es imposible que la
teoría de la fiscalidad sea cierta como
como era imposible que esos eran o sea
el autor de los crímenes
y entonces lo que hicimos nosotros lo
que hice yo con el libro es darle voz lo
que hizo tan era hace años con el
documental es volver a dar la voz a
nelson serrano y contar su historia y
eso es lo que estamos haciendo y tú me
dices como que se puede hacer levantar
la voz siempre sin levantar la voz y nos
ayuda a muchas cosas y que lean el libro
que vean el documental que pongan un
tweet lo que sea todos los ayudas
me quedan 30 segundos para este tema
están haciendo ya señas aquí ya se
convirte algo personal para ti sí se
terminó convirtiendo en una historia
fíjate cuando uno publicó un libro
cuando ya el libro está editado el libro
de los de los lectores y chao se acabó
la historia esta historia no esta
historia la verdad es que me sigue
todavía a mí y yo la sigo yo estoy unido
a esta historia pegado a esta historia y
creo que voy a estar siempre porque
tiene que haber un desenlace un vídeo
jala yo lo vea ojalá oscar muchísimas
gracias por estar con la gráfica de
frank sentí cuatro aguardar un placer un
gusto haber conversado con usted sobre
este caso tan interesante y ojalá pues
nelson cerrada no tenga una vida que se
merece y pueda salir pronto de la cárcel
pues ya cuando se cumple su inocencia
muchas gracias muchísimas gracias a
ustedes también muchísimas gracias
entonces por siempre acompañarnos un día
más con un invitado más de aquí de
nuestro invitado del día de directo
américa así que continuar con nosotros
hay mucho más para ver todavía en
nuestro programa y los veo